you think we've locked down too late
though i think i've said all everything
i've i've said lots of things about all
of that already through mp's matt
hancock's 100 000 tests target though
why didn't you support him at the time i
think you're confused about that the
um there already was a target before
hancock ever blurted out onto tv so
that's a misunderstanding of the
situation the problem with the target
was not having a target
problem was a it should be more than 100
000 b um the way he announced it caused
a lot of problems
wasn't the fact of having a target of a
hundred thousand which actually had
already been in place
so you've misunderstood what actually
happened would you say you suffered from
from group
think well i've already explained
to the mps about all of that
did you actually watch what i said yes
okay so you already know all that yes on
the report today they also
sided with you on the
in the report in terms of some of the
things that you did say um about
how
you know not
that people should have stood up and
intervened but the intimidation side of
things made that difficult would you
kind of agree with that
the intimidation
well the government system for dealing
with crises is a disaster as i wrote in
2019
so
again i explained all that in
when i spoke to the mps
system was bad
for many years before kovid
me and others put into place work to try
and improve the system in 2020 after the
first wave unfortunately the prime
minister being the joke that he is has
not pushed that work through
now we have a joke prime minister and a
joker lead leading the labor party and
we obviously need a new political system
see ya thanks have a good day